giftalarm heute an der oder ein
massensterben von tieren im fluss
tote fische so weit das auge reicht
tausende verendete tiere liegen am ufer
der oder welse störe hechte karpfen
forelle auch vögel und biber sind
betroffen ihre nahrungsgrundlage
vergiftet ein massensterben im
grenzfluss zwischen deutschland und
polen bilder aus lebus in brandenburg
grund könnte ein chemieunfall im
nachbarland sein dass giftmüll ihn ist
wahrscheinlich aus einer polnischen
fabrik ins wasser gelangt messi turin
ist eine farblose flüssigkeit mit öligem
geruch die behörden warnen inzwischen
vor dem verzehr von fisch aus der oder
auch zur bewässerung soll das wasser
nicht genutzt werden baden ist verboten
es ist ein erschütterndes bild die
gesamte oder scheint tot zu sein und
nicht nur die fische sind betroffen auch
freilaufende hauskatzen sind in gefahr
wenn sie die verendeten tiere fressen
unglaublich die polnische regierung hat
deutschland anfangs nicht informiert am
wochenende waren noch kinder in der
alten oder bei lebus baden wie sich das
gift neutralisieren lässt und wie der
fischbestand wiederhergestellt werden
soll aufgaben die die deutsch-polnische
grenzregion auf jahre beschäftigen wird
[Musik]
unsere potter tillmann ist vor ortete
dein eindruck bitte
viele viele tote fische im wasser große
zander kapitale tiere von denen so sagte
mir ein anderer angler eigentlich freuen
würden dass sie sie einmal fangen würden
und wie sind die elendig verendet und ja
es scheint tatsächlich jetzt immer mehr
heraus zu kristallisieren dass die
ursache chemikalien sind das hat jetzt
auch die die das umweltamt brandenburg
bekannt gegeben dass sich alles darauf
dass er alles darauf hinaus läuft das
ist eine toxikologische ursache und
polnische medien berichten jetzt auch
schon davon dass womöglich eine
papierfabrik bei breslau oder ursprung
sein könnte
normalerweise funktioniert ja die
zusammenarbeit im deutsch polnischen
grenzgebiet gebiet da gibt es ja viele
formen der zusammenarbeit irgendeine
erklärung dafür wie das so schief
gegangen sein kann keine erklärung nach
deutschland
tatsächlich ist das sind das immer noch
offene fragen und das umweltamt
brandenburg fordert jetzt auch die
polnische seite auch alles offenzulegen
und zusammenzuarbeiten was halt den
menschen hier in der region auf will das
auf einmal der wasserstand um 30
zentimeter zum montag hin stieg und
danach die fische sterben also ist
scheint so eine art flutwelle mit dem
gift mit den organischen stoffen so
nennt ist das umweltamt brandenburg
hierdurch gegangen seien und tatsächlich
ein großteil der fische getötet sagen
man sieht immer noch ein paar kleine
fische herumschwimmen
und da haben wir
immer die leitung ist eingefroren daher
will ich wieder spricht er weiter
ja also ich hatte gerade gesagt
das große gerade große fische hier tot
im wasser schwimmen und dass auch andere
wirbeltiere in gefahr sind das hat das
umweltamt brandenburg
verkündet dass wirbeltiere durch diese
chemikalien in gefahr sind das sind
wurden auch tote bieber gesichtet mögl
und ja die aufklärung läuft das
umweltamt brannten morgen genauere
erkenntnisse verkünden
massensterben in der oder möglicherweise
durch chemikalien die aus polen
eingeleitet worden sind und natürlich
soll auch keiner im fluss baden am
momentan der mann war das danke
[Musik]